tanner hawk looking for that first win
although he's thrown the ball very very
well he is owen three with an era of
3.12 the center and hit well verdugo
going back and looking up and high off
the wall
and kepler rounding second on his way to
third
and it's a lead off triple for max
kepler
missed a home run by maybe a couple of
feet
and i think that ballpark and detroit
are maybe the only ones where that's not
actually a home run
passed him at 94 miles an hour got him
to swing and miss strike three last fall
up in the zone good fastball keeping the
golf balance mixing it up a little bit
here and there fastball up in the zone
for strike three you need somebody to
pick you up after rooker strikes out
this is the guy you'd want to see
walking up to the plate
and a patient to right and as he's done
all season long polanco comes through
drives in a run it's one to nothing oh
we say it all the time
great man right spot
and it's swung out and popped up into
short left bogart's a lengthy run out
there coming on a sliding play is
schwarber he bailed everybody out with
that catch made a nice sliding grab for
round number two and that's exactly what
you want the outfielder to take charge
xander was going after that ball i
thought he was going to get it all of a
sudden kyle took charge and made an
outstanding play right there with a
sliding catch
trying to go up the middle
throws off balance tough play but he
made it got the throw in the air on
target one run in red sox coming up
griffin jacks has been developing he's
been getting better each time out he's
been very good in the month of august
2-0 seems like he's getting more
comfortable every time he takes that
mound it'll be interesting to see how he
reacts to pitching in fenway park
popped up
and a long run for a rise
[Music]
but with room he almost overran it with
the infield shifted a ryze had a long
ways to go and almost went too far two
down
that got the umpire halley in big time
that one rung tom's bell xander was
right on that pitch fastball up and in
oh it did get him good
that looks like tom will hang in
fly ball right field plenty of room for
kepler
and on eight pitches griffin jacks
protects a one nothing lead with a one
two three first and tom a very tough guy
stepping aside so we have a delay in the
game phil cousy will go inside and
change and he'll get into the home plate
on firing gear so that's a reason for
the delay garbage short lead at first
big hole on the left side
up the middle that gets through kiki's
got it
got the out at second got the out at
first
and he swings and misses on the slider
so tanner huck gets out of it he strands
too
all right breaking ball gets a swing and
a miss jack's upset about something
upset that he struck out one of the best
hitters
fast wall hit to right
kepler coming in and a diving catch by
kepler and right field a fine play by
kepler to take a hit away from jd
martinez making an impact early in this
game starting off with a triple score in
the game's first run and then he got the
legs involved showing that he's feeling
good
yesterday's hero travis shaw in the
bottom of the third inning twins leading
one nothing his career he talked about
it afterwards too he's gonna swing and
ride this one that's up to right kepler
back hits that one goodbye
wow
right on cue look at this
well maybe something stirred with that
granny yesterday
bringing back some good memories
and he's done it again
and back to back at bats
he goes deep and the red sox have tied
him
full count
and a breaking ball gets a strike three
and again jax snaps his head down in
frustration one down he's a competitor
you know he's pretty even keel guy off
the off the mountain when he takes that
pitching mount he takes that rubber he
steps out there he expects himself to
succeed new shoreboro for one
and that's going to miss for ball four
so he's on again that's 21 consecutive
games for kyle schwarber and with two
down he's on in front of xander bogart's
louisiana
and there's a base hit to left field a
hot ground ball past devers and into the
outfield grass a rise of the board
leading off the forward
tough pitch a sinker inside to get him
he strikes him out so down goes garber
one away one down a ride still at first
and now nick gordon
gordon left it high to center fairly
deep for dugo going back still back and
he can't make the play
rounding second on his way to third
arise and gordon gets the third hit for
the twins big spot here for ceno drew
will walk in his return to the lineup
right center field it makes it and it
will score two runs a smash out of the
reach of hernandez and the twins quickly
retake the lead one man away the batter
verdugo drew a walk in the second
base hit
headed toward the alley kepler trying to
cut it heading for third denver's
heading into second base is verdugo
and the sox are in business second and
third one down and the socks knocking on
the door second and third
[Music]
high high fly ball deep left field way
back
gone
that is a beautiful thing looked like he
hung a slider in the middle of the plate
there touch them all young man
for a three-run shot
and the red sox in front
hernandez lead things off
it's that one softly but arise will be
tested he throws and up the line
keegan taking off for second
as it rolls into foul territory takes a
wide turn as the throw is zipped to
third and he's standing in scoring
position now raphael deborah's will
attempt to pick up this run
two down the o2
road to right fair ball
down the line a run in [ __ ] scores
easily and raphael has another rbi
there's number 91 sox lead it five to
three
two on two out
and a high fly ball that checked deep to
left field brooker back to the wall
feeling for the wall
high off the monster here to score his
divers here comes martinez the throw is
late
and two more score
and a sox with plenty of breathing room
now thanks to alex verdugo
7-3 the young man is getting hot once
again
on a renfrow looking to keep it rolling
he already has a three-run homer tonight
this one he lays in two and he's got
another one way out of here
two-run homer
five rbis for hunter renfro
he's tearing the cover off of the month
of august and dave that was no cheapy no
sir
deep to right field
and over the head of renfro still in the
field of play and garber will glide into
second with a lead-off double
[Music]
coming in
and polanco lifts it high and deep to
laugh and the twins are coming back
again tonight two in the seventh with
polanco hitting his 23rd home run of the
year just like that it's a three run
ball game and say polanco hasn't missed
too many pitches like the one he missed
the swing before this one got himself a
hanging breaking ball and crushed it
over the monster now you're one swing
away from tying this ball game up
slap to left another base hit for a rise
his second of the ball game jordan
doubled off the center field fence
scoring a run on the fourth big spot
here for the rookie hit to the outfield
might get the twins back within one
off the middle and through for a hat
donaldson scores a rise behind him and
gordon delivers a huge two-out hit and
the twins are within one yeah just when
it felt like this game was out of reach
twins were down big and
a big two-out knock right there from
gordon a single in front of [ __ ] one for
four he has a base hit
high deep drive man did he crush this
that's gone
and there's your breathing room and the
red sox lead it 11-8 3-1 red sox lead
donaldson leads off
and a high fastball lifted high and deep
to center
and gone a mammoth home run for
donaldson and the lead is cut back to
two last hope for the twins jake cave
another 3-2 pitch runners go
softly line caught
arroyo at the grab and the ball game
red sox had him all the way
11
to nine the final score
tonight at fenway
yeah
kind of an exhausted team hug
you